In this tutorial, we’ll define the phi and
psi angles of an amino acid, use a 3D model
to visualize them, and see how they’re measured.
Finally, we’ll learn how to translate what
we see in the 3D model to a 2D Newman projection,
which might sound familiar if you’ve taken
an organic chemistry course.
In order to carry out the functions that keep
you alive, proteins fold up into very specific
three-dimensional shapes. The peptide sequence
curls and bends into the secondary structural
elements of helices and sheets, and those
can further fold into the tertiary structure
of a protein.
When crystallographers and structural biologists
are figuring out the structures of these important
macromolecules they place the atoms where
they appear to go in 3D space based on their
structural data. But there can be some ambiguity
in the model, so they need a way to verify
that their structures make sense based on
actual allowable molecular geometries.
Enter the Ramachandran plot. In 1963, the
Indian physicist G. N. Ramachandran described
a standard way to define the geometry of a
given amino acid in a polypeptide chain. Ramachandran’s
team noted that some geometries aren’t possible
due to sterics. In other words, a given amino
acid cannot adopt some conformations in a
polypeptide chain because of unfavorable crowding
with the adjacent residues. And, when the
two backbone angles are plotted, there are
distinct regions for the unique elements of
the secondary structure.
Phi and psi are examples of dihedral angles,
which are, by definition, the angle between
two intersecting planes, shown in yellow in
this image. Notice that the carbonyl and the
adjacent nitrogen are shown with dotted bonds.
Remember that peptide bonds, and amide linkages
in general, have significant contribution
from a resonance structure with double bond
character. So much so that the nitrogen and
carbonyl group are coplanar. This puts six
atoms in a single plane on each side of the
alpha carbon.
Though we don’t have free rotation about
amide bonds, we can rotate around each bond
coming from the alpha carbon atom. Let’s
head over to our 3D model to explore this.
We’ll start with a tripeptide made up of
three alanine residues, and for good measure,
let’s show the peptide bonds and label the
N-terminus and C-terminus.
When we measure phi and psi angles for our
central alanine, we’ll need to look at some
atoms in the surrounding amino acids. But
we can simplify our structure by removing
atoms that are not needed to view phi or psi
for the central alanine. Those atoms can obscure
other atoms and make the analysis of the angle
a little more difficult.
The phi angle is defined by rotation about
this bond, from the alpha carbon to nitrogen,
which I’ve colored magenta. And the psi
angle is given by the bond from the alpha
carbon to the carbonyl, which I’ve colored
green. In order to understand the angles,
we need to set this up by looking straight
at the alpha carbon directly down the bond
of interest. So, if we’re looking for the
phi angle, we’ll orient the structure like
this. And if we’re considering the psi angle,
we’ll have to orient the structure like
this.
When we look down the bond for the phi angle,
this nitrogen is going to be hidden behind
the alpha carbon. What we’ll be comparing
is the angle between these two carbonyl carbon
atoms.
And when we look down the bond for our psi
angle, this carbon atom is going to be hidden.
So here, we’ll be comparing the angle between
these two nitrogen atoms. So, essentially,
we consider a four atom pattern when looking
at phi and psi.
To translate this to our Newman projection,
we can imagine model as a clock. Looking directly
down our bond of interest, we’ll need to
make sure to place the nitrogen or carbonyl
carbon that is attached to the alpha carbon
at noon. If we draw out just the front carbon
of our Newman projection, this group has to
point up. For the phi angle, our hydrogen
points left and our methyl points right.
When we draw the front carbon atom for psi,
we’re looking at the alpha carbon from the
opposite side, so our hydrogen points right
and our methyl is on the left.
Now, it’s time to consider what’s going
on with our back carbon, and we’ll do this
in detail for just the phi angle to start.
Let’s hide a couple more atoms to make the
carbonyl easier to see.
Dihedral angles range in value from negative
180 to positive 180 degrees. If the two carbonyl
carbons are eclipsed, the angle is 0. Let’s
start there, and move incrementally to a phi
angle of 180 degrees. Going back to our clock,
as the carbonyl on the back carbon moves from
noon to 6, the phi angles are positive. Let’s
pause at 90 degrees to draw the groups on
the back carbon onto our Newman projection.
The carbon of the carbonyl is sitting at a
90-degree angle, so we can place it here.
And this hydrogen, the only other group on
the back nitrogen atom is on the opposite
side, 180 degrees from the carbonyl. We can
add that in, and we’ve done it.
Once we pass 180 degrees, or 6 o’clock if
we’re using our clock analogy, the values
for phi are negative. So, if we’re between
6 and midnight, we have a negative phi angle.
Let’s pause at negative 140 degrees and
draw the Newman projection again. This is
a typical phi angle for an amino acid found
in a beta sheet. And let’s check out what
that looks like from another angle.
Moving right along, negative 60 degrees is
a typical phi angle for an alpha helix. Let’s
show this Newman projection too.
Now, let’s focus on the psi angle in our
model. We’ll rotate our structure, and hide
just a couple more atoms to clearly see the
nitrogen atom that’s bound to the alpha
carbon. We’ll just show two angles for this
model, and the first is a typical psi angle
for an alpha helix, which is negative 50 degrees.
Adding the Newman projection, we can see the
nitrogen on the back carbon is at about 10
o’clock. For an amino acid in an alpha helix,
both the phi and psi angles are negative.
We can see this on our Ramachandran plot.
And, we’ll notice that for beta sheet, psi
is positive, as we can see from this region
of the plot.
Positive 130 degrees is a typical value for
the beta sheet psi angle. Let’s show that
in our model. And now let’s draw that up
as a Newman projection. Nice.
To sum up, let’s break this process down
into three general steps:
Step 1: Look down the bond of interest with
the alpha carbon in front.
Step 2: There will be either a nitrogen or
a carbonyl directly attached to the alpha
carbon, depending on whether you’re looking
down the phi or psi bond. Place this group
at noon.
Step 3: If the other nitrogen or carbonyl
is between noon and 6 o clock, the angle is
positive. If it’s between 6 and midnight,
the angle is negative.
I hope this tutorial has helped you begin
to make sense of phi and psi angles and Ramachandran
plots. It’s one thing to watch me demonstrate
this, and another to play around with a 3D
model of your own. So I encourage you to check
out the video description where there’s
a link to an amazing page on the website proteopedia,
where you can explore phi and psi angles for
yourself. And if you find this challenging,
you are not alone. This type of detailed structural
analysis is difficult at first, but gets easier
with practice. Happy modeling.